and another possession for the warriors
via lisa from d
and mcgee with the rebound feels like
golden state for the first 12 minutes
been faster to the ball
yeah yeah just a step
level of multiple efforts quickness
and there's going to be a foul against
the warriors jonathan kaminga the rookie
that's his second personal
chris paul seems to
school rookies on every available
opportunity
[Applause]
you got to know it you know how many
rookies i've spoken to look at
and now
he took their first couple free throws
he gets a few more some teams will find
you if you foul chris paul on that rip
through okay yeah
that's a sweet pot i don't want to win
that point because he's caught a lot of
guys with that rip through do you know
how many rookies i've spoken to this
year that i asked them what was your
welcome to the nba moment they say oh
and chris paul got me on the rift oh
yeah but you know on the playground
we're not calling that no no in fact
that may start a physical fight